- [Narrator] In the skies
over the Spanish province
of Ciudad Real lies something unexpected
abandoned silos have been transformed
into enormous works of art.
Together, they form the world's
largest open-air museum.
But what makes this project truly unique
are the people that came
together to create it all.
(soft music)
(speaking Spanish)
- [Narrator] To create
his giant works of art
Okuda partnered with an
organization called Laborvalia
that works with people with
intellectual disabilities.
(soft, upbeat music)
(speaking Spanish)
- [Narrator] What started
as a single mural by Okuda
has grown to cover 10 different silos
by artists from around the world.
(soft, upbeat music)
The latest step of the
project is to transform
the interior of one these massive silos.
(speaking Spanish)
- [Narrator] But in the end, for Okuda,
it's the creative journey
that's been the most gratifying.
(speaking Spanish)
(bell ringing)